we model three different type of
Landscapes that are typically used in
arid regions and that includes music
Zurich and Oasis landscape I think a
better way to understand them is to
think of them as three different type of
cars
magic
landscape is like High Juice water
landscape so I I like to call it like a
gas guzzling car that is classic car
that is aesthetically pleasant but in
the long run it's not really efficient
um the other type of landscape or the
other end of the spectrum is Zurich
landscape which are very precise water
use or low water use and I like to call
it electrical car because it's not
really consuming a lot of gas
and then in the middle is the Oasis
landscape with a medium water use and
it's precisely the cocktail of two these
two to Landscapes which in this case I
like to say hybrid car but that Oasis
landscape is what we found in our study
to be much more efficient in overall and
that efficiency is in terms of outdoor
thermal Comforts and irrigation water
requirement and what we found was that
um
Oasis landscape's temperature was
comparable to the magic landscape which
is supposed to be cooler at the noon
time
and then what surprised us was that it's
at the night time the it's temperature
profile was comparable to the xeric
landscape which is the low water use
landscape and even those Eric landscape
had
four degrees cooling at the nighttime
magic had eight degrees cooling at that
point and so that kind of was surprising
to us as to how the ulyssa's landscape
had this dual personality and I think
when it comes to irrigation water
requirement the results were pretty
counter not counter intuitive where
music has higher water use overall and
then Oasis had
you know was the second higher
um water user so
yeah those were our findings